all right let's give you some good news
shall we for the first time
ever unlv and unr will play on nevada
day weekend and for the first time ever
the battle for the fremont cannon is
going to be played at allegiant stadium
john treach reminding us why this
matchup means so much to everybody john
well it's 545 pounds battle born and
rivalry worn the john c fremont cannon
is the most expensive trophy in college
football
who knew one painted artifact could
solidify and separate
north versus south and red versus blue
tomorrow there will only be one either
nevada reno or nevada las vegas
will conquer the cannon the last two
seasons unlv has had miserable years
all was seemingly lost until the final
game was won
the rebels roared to the greatest
comeback in school history in 2018
erasing a three touchdown deficit
to stun the wolf pack last year after
their coach was fired
a three and eight unlv team traveled to
the frigid sierra nevadas
and won the first overtime game in
match-up history
it's a rivalry where the records are
meaningless but bragging rights and
cannon possession
means everything the first member i had
was my freshman year they just blew us
out the water
it was like 45 out of 10 and watching
them
pull the cannon out um and you know just
spray painted blue already on our field
was so disrespectful
and i just knew like this was like a
serious game and
we got to take them serious because when
it comes to it whoever pulls that cannon
out
is a special moment for them also this
rivalry impacts our everyday lives one
of my favorite people i've ever covered
wintourino channel 8's beloved kristen
drummond went to reno
my boss's son goes to unr you have to be
civil and mature
it's hard but also keep that cannon red
thank you john for that perspective
a lot of people here both sides go red